foreign
[Music]
am I Audible
sounds good I can hear myself on my
phone so that's good let me add some
background music
what we just had there
sounded pretty good I'm not sure if
that's playing though
it's been so long since I've been
streaming
literally
uh media Source safe
Loop
the crazy time so in case you don't know
um I'm sure there's going to be a few
people in the chat who've uh who've been
there for a while uh on the channel and
some people who might be newer you might
be subscribed just recently so just as a
little history lesson I actually started
this channel four and a half years ago
in late
2018 so it was uh roughly I think I
started the channel late September but
then I started publishing my first video
I think early mid-october on the channel
and uh it's it's kind of crazy that it's
been five years already
um
I think the first major Milestone video
I had was a Zorro character analysis
which was a I think early 2019 that was
the first video of mine that ever hit
100 000 and actually I think a million
views as well which was kind of nuts to
see
and um I think that the channel has gone
through like a lot of phases honestly
it's been I start so in case you don't
know I started off doing character
analyzes which was a lot of fun doing
like I was really into a story analysis
um then at at a point I had a a really
fun one-piece podcast with uh Mr morge
who is a one of the people in the one
piece Community I I owe a lot to because
he he reached out to me very early on
um into my YouTube Journey
and encouraged me to uh to keep posting
he gave me some advice we started
hanging out talking
and kind of grew together for a while
had the podcast and he kind of I think
started focusing a little bit more on
his on his business and not so much on
YouTube while I kind of went all in on
YouTube but uh yeah he's a great friend
of mine
fantastic person fantastic YouTuber uh
so big shout out to uh to you morge
um really appreciate everything same
goes for a lot of people in the in the
one piece community and also outside
who've been a big part of making this
happen uh particularly like the in case
you don't know the people who inspired
me to to even start the channel That was
a teching and joy boy theories to uh
very OG
uh channels I'd say
and uh yeah I started watching them when
I was first living in Japan for an
internship in 2018. I was just gonna
bike to work I actually have a whole
video that I'm gonna make about that but
uh still you're gonna get a little bit
of the story here and so I just I was
really hardcore into one piece at that
point I was like I wanted to know more
and so I actually looked up on YouTube
stuff looked for people who I could
listen to found those two and I kind of
was like okay I'm kind of curious if I
could do that as well if you know what I
mean so a really big shout out to those
guys then there's uh brago Roger like a
lot of people who who really supported
me a lot and I I really appreciate how
they always welcome people into the
community with open arms
um I know I'm personally a little bit
bad with I guess uh a little bit bad
with uh you know Community engagement
but but nonetheless like nothing goes
unnoticed and a big big warm thank you
and shout out to all the the Fantastic
uh other one piece and Anime creators
who accomplish accompany me on the on
the journey so far and also of course
the the trash taste guys
um Sydney from sidnab
um so like so many great people I got to
know quite recently roughly a year ago
when I moved back to Japan but they've
also been incredibly supportive Joey
gond Connor of course
yeah it's been fantastic you know like
talking to different people
uh yeah just just crazy
um okay we got some oh my God suddenly
donations coming in
thank you very much in case you don't
know I'm actually German I'm not sure
how how common knowledge that actually
is but much appreciated we have a very
uh hardcore uh base of German fans in
the channel which I always appreciate so
thank you very much for the
congratulations there
um mama do Musa says will you ever do
character story analysis or are you not
interested in it anymore slash it does
not make as many views I think it's just
we did like character analyzes on on all
the major characters and obviously like
if I had felt that there was more to
discuss there I would have kept doing it
but also at the same time I feel like um
my personal thoughts on each character I
think I've shared everything on the
channel and also I do think that my
personal interest just kind of shifted
over time so it was kind of analyzes
videos then it was more uh Theory videos
as you know that was a really big thing
on the channel for almost two years I'm
sure a lot of people of you came from
the big one piece Theory and many others
that followed which was a lot of fun I
just think um
we kind of all collectively ran out of
great theories I might be the only one
who feels that way but me personally I
was kind of feeling like okay uh the
theories like either I came up with or
people shared with me kindly enough I
felt like they were getting less like
getting so specific and Niche that I
personally felt like I wanted to try new
content which is uh where like now we've
kind of moved on to you know the what
ifs which are a ton like a ton of fun to
make super happy that you guys seem to
enjoy them or many of you do at least
very grateful the shorts have been a lot
of fun rating all the devil fruits and
everything we had a lot of fun writing
those and yeah just also it's it's it's
I enjoy making a little bit more General
one-piece content you might have
probably seen like more explainer type
videos ranking videos just being
creative and and trying out different
things so yeah
um
that that's I guess my take on the
analysis videos but maybe for for other
manga or anime in the future
the German diaspora supports you that is
much appreciated thank you very much
uh Caleb Brown congrats on the 1 million
well not not quite yet we're not uh not
quite there yet I also mod for mortgage
brago and some other in the community if
you need a mod to help with this Pam
keep up the great work here's the 2
million much appreciated uh I will keep
you in mind calib I'm not sure how much
I'll be live streaming in the future but
in case I do I'll I'll definitely keep
you in mind thank you very much
then we have a donation from a Arab user
I think uh thank you very much I cannot
read Arab sadly so I can't spell your
name but much appreciated thank you very
much
uh
all right uh let's see what are we did I
miss oh my God people you're just
donating that's that was not the
intention behind that stream but
nonetheless much appreciated oh uh
Illuminati thank you joined as a member
that is much appreciated wow thank you
very much that that does help the
channel a lot and it's always great
seeing people with a little badge in the
in the comments I always read everything
you guys post
Johnny Smith says I started one piece
and caught up this year good job and uh
how long did it take you is the good
question only catching up in the last
week an insanely good series deserves
only the best YouTubers bring your video
binging your videos since I finished
can't wait for more that that does mean
a lot again I know um not the most
active in in my own comments and
everything but nonetheless I I do read
most comments at least the first day a
video is out because at some point it
does get a little bit much to read but
uh always always oh I'm frozen
oh no
the sub oh the sub count is frozen oh
that's probably because I'm reading the
chat okay okay I'll go back here maybe I
should read it on my phone this is so
unprofessional okay oh now
Oh shoot no what
ah that was so fat no no no no are we
are we cracking that so fast oh my God I
was just I didn't know that the the the
the count would freeze when I was
reading the chat no
oh my God we're so close guys oh okay
before we hit this I have to say this
means so much and I will get into more
detail obviously when we hit that but
right now like my heart is just racing
and uh I think before we hit this big
shout out to my team uh Richard Madge
Jafar Andrew Blake uh link
Ruben aval like ah dude I have so many
great people that work with me and I
really like this belongs to all of them
probably even more so than me
oh here we go that that's the that's
what I was waiting for we got up there
and we're gonna go to back down but but
we got time people we got time I'm gonna
try to keep a little bit of an eye
oh someone else gotta became a member uh
but the chat's moving so fast I can't
catch you
I appreciate it though
you guys are too fast
1991.
eluna and I thank you
uh 990 oh my God guys
I'm literally I'm sweating both because
of this and because it's so hot here I
think it has like uh I don't even know
uh like 100 degrees Fahrenheit they're
like 32 degrees still Celsius
my God there we go people let's go let's
see if it goes back down oh there he
goes there he goes but but we're
counting it we're counting it
let's keep it above let's keep it above
the million oh my God
wow
that looks
insane
oh my God
dude guys I appreciate you so so so so
so much
thank you really it it does it does mean
a lot
um I know it's it's it's such such a
generic thing that I think so many
YouTubers uh love to say but but I
generally genuinely
appreciate every single one of you
um I'm so happy that
I can
brighten up your day with the video or
you know at least get you get you a
little bit riled up about one piece
whatever it may be it does it does mean
a lot like generally I'm very touched if
if I wasn't if my toxic masculinity
didn't uh prohibit me from doing so I'd
probably cry right now but I think I
think I'm gonna manage not to
um but yeah very very moved wow
a million does look insane
I never ever again I started this
channel because I was biking down
towards Shinjuku in Tokyo you know uh
still in University listening to some uh
one piece chapter reviews or something
and I was like you know what I wonder if
people would enjoy listening to me while
they're at work and just hear my
thoughts and
the fact that that now ended up
not even five years later turning into a
Channel with a great team of fantastic
artists
editors researchers writers everything
and a million of you guys is just
absolutely in in saying that
it's just that is stupid
it's so stupid and I love it I love that
one piece is just such a unique special
series that I mean look at it a million
people who just love to hear someone
like me
share their opinion about the
series
um
wow
wow that is so cool
um
yeah it's it is just the the best story
in the world uh no no question about it
I will also say honorable mention to to
a few other shows I've covered on my
channel
um as you might know I also did a quite
long character analysis series on dudes
of kaisen I did some Hunter Hunter and
recently we started doing some Demon
Slayer we have some other cool stuff
coming up some Naruto and some other
more secret projects that I do hope you
guys will enjoy we're gonna add in some
non-one-piece content a little bit in
the future but don't worry the one piece
is here to stay of course
um we're gonna ride it all the way to
the end and honestly probably even way
past that because there is so much to
talk about
but yeah
um
wow
insane what an that is so crazy
thank you I I want to try to catch up
with uh with some donations but can I
just click here sorry I is this is like
the most unprofessional stream ever I
hope
Connor or Garns or any of my other or
Rob none of my other streamers streamer
friends are watching because this is the
this is literally trashed here streaming
um Pax live joined as a member thank you
very much oh elune and I actually didn't
only become a member he gifted 10
memberships
let me see I can't allow gifts by
activating them here
so they are available now I don't
actually know how gifted memberships
work on YouTube but much appreciated
thank you very much I appreciate it I
guess
someone can or do they get randomly
distributed I have no idea but this is
awesome
um
then Rama says thank you so much for
your happy cont for your content happy
one Millie thank you so much ramus
appreciate it a lot I I mean
maybe maybe I should uh
emulsify shout out thank you Roger I see
in the comments okay I'm so sorry I've
not been reading the comments because
I've just been talking to the camera I'm
sure there's I'm sure I missed a bunch
of people I I'm so so sorry if you
messaged and uh I missed you uh sorry
I'm sorry apologies also to Roger for
the crappy stream I know you deserve
better my friends yeah shout out to
Roger too
um
I think really I mean there's there's a
lot of people who make the the one piece
community and the one-piece content
creator Community grade but Roger is
definitely a stand-up character he's
he's brought together so many people has
organized so many reveries
um whenever there's anything anything
that's you know worrisome if it's
copyright strikes or if there's any beef
between creators or something Rogers
always there to clean it up to help out
everyone just a great guy
so uh thank you Roger and shout out to
you I hope to see I think I'm going to
see you soon actually in Japan which I'm
really excited for
ah guys this is
such a great moment thank you it does it
does mean a lot yeah I mean emotional
time for a dude uh then then Kushi rides
and it is true I'm a little bit
at a loss for words honestly and I don't
even know I'm like reading the chat and
just thinking what to discuss
brick War says can I have a shout out
brick War I'm gonna shout you out you
get you get your shout out of course
cologne oh man this is also so cool like
I've been seeing so many people from all
over the world engage and follow with
the channel which is just so awesome
um appreciate it so so much thank you uh
I think I think most people actually the
biggest chunk is from the us but we have
people from all over Europe Africa Asia
Australia South America a bunch of
people I always see in the comment which
is just so so cool
um I personally love
you know learning about new cultures and
traveling and learning new languages so
seeing people from all over the world
engage with the content is just such a
blessing honestly
uh let's see
we have Yosh 100 went back on Twitch
slacker uh yeah so I I had a very good
I'd say uh streak of twitch streams last
year but it was honestly
while it was very fun
um I I didn't like it took away such a
chunk from my time on my of making
videos that in the end I decided I could
not keep it up just because I feel like
if you stream I mean right now might be
a bit of an exception but usually when
you stream it's gonna be for at least
three four five hours I did stream a
bunch of Pokemon
um so I I do enjoy streaming a lot but
it is very time consuming and I was just
at some point feeling I might rather
invest that time into making better and
more videos for you guys uh rather than
than playing Pokemon even though that
was a blast and I appreciate all the
people who were there for it maybe who
knows maybe I mean if people want to I
might be streaming more on YouTube about
anime stuff in the future something I'm
definitely thinking about
Pax life being here from before the
wanna report so happy to see you grow
this much also won some someday make a
Channel about something don't know yet
but you inspired me dude my man
um I I mean just do it honestly I again
I started this as a pure like I wanted
to do something on YouTube I loved one
piece and I guess it was kind of like
coping for me also having to leave Japan
so those three things I never never
imagined this to turn out like become a
career being a YouTuber talking about
one piece another anime like
no get the out of here
um but yeah that's that's exactly what
happened and I am very grateful for it
uh Nick King how come nobody talks about
mihawk's ancestor being a fraud I need
answers to answer Zahara mihawk's
ancestor
who do you do you mean shanks's ancestor
dude are we talking about Garling
because I think uh he's more Shanks his
ancestor or or am I missing something
with mihawk please let me know what you
mean
um Jeffrey Langley are you going to lick
your gold one million subscriber play oh
my God guys okay so again uh clearly
Jeffrey is a real OG
when did I get this I think I got it
late
2020 during covid right before I moved
back to Japan uh right around Christmas
I I hit uh 100 000 Subs so basically
two and a half years ago
and I did make a video where I licked my
silver play button I have since unlisted
that video because
I think like two weeks later I've
I suddenly get into the realization that
it was a very embarrassing video to make
um but hey if someone saved the link for
whatever it's not private it's just
unlisted so maybe you can find it if
it's still out there
oh all right guys
um yeah I will I will
um in case you don't know I have a
second Channel called Manu were starting
I mean I already started making some
videos last year uh but this year I'm
gonna make more videos and I'm actually
working on a video right now where uh
I'm kind of trying to tell my story
um of how moving to Japan basically
changed my life which is exactly what
have what like culminated in in tonight
which is just uh again insane and
um I I will give hopefully a much more
coherence and interesting and Visually a
lot more pleasing presentation than
tonight
um so in case you aren't interested in
that you can find the the second channel
uh it's linked in my main Channel under
the channel sections you can wait for
the video there I I think that one is
going to drop probably uh towards uh
September end of August Maybe
but we have another I have like a cool
Okinawa Vlog coming there I'm gonna I
think I discussed the one piece live
action on the channel so it's just going
to be a bit of a variety Japan vloggy
anime channel in case you're interested
oh oh my God and
Nick King also asks from oda's Monsters
comic with ryuma also congrats on the
Millie oh oh that's the guy you mean
um is that con I I don't think that's
confirmed to be mihawk's ancestor but I
mean monsters in case you don't know
that's the kind of one shot that Oda
made that was kind of
an early version of one piece and some
of it is Canon like ryuma who's the main
character and uh kind of It kind of was
like a test run for One Piece if you
haven't read it definitely check it out
maybe we should make a video on that
that would be interesting
uh again guys I mean thank you so much
for watching so many people tuning in so
many great comments I will
um actually wrap this up now because it
is very late uh it's deep into the night
and uh I think I'm waking up my entire
family who are kindly enough tolerating
this which I appreciate thank you but
yeah thank you so so much guys
um I really like all I can say is I I
hope I can make even better
um and more awesome content for you
starting now
um I mean one million is such an insane
Milestone I'm not really thinking that
like something like 10 million is
realistic
so I'm just putting that to the side I'm
very happy we hit this so grateful that
you were all here to share this with me
um and yeah I promise that me and the
team we're gonna try to work really hard
to make even better videos that look
better sound better or more interesting
and yeah excited to try a lot of new
stuff also
um One Piece related also other anime
I'm really excited to talk about and
yeah I hope you're going to be there for
it and
um thank you to everyone who donated
thank you to everyone who showed up and
messaged and really
yeah I'm just beyond words this this I
just moved this means so much
thank you wherever you are have a great
day have a great night thanks for being
a part of the channel
um
yeah you enjoying the videos
means the world to me
um love you all and stay safe and read
more one piece I guess have a good night
everyone
let me just quickly see oh I got one
more donation okay Nick King who is
apparently having too much money
um or we have another so we have more
gifted members is that from earlier
did you did you gift another 10
memberships illuna and I thank you very
much in case you did if you didn't and
you only did it once that's still plenty
and way too much and thank you very much
I much appreciate it thank you and the
King uh oh sorry that was the that was
the donation from earlier okay so we're
good we're good
good night
thank you one million in sane I
will pass out
in happiness now thank you
all right now I just gotta stop the
stream somehow